you guys want to see my Coachella look
get ready sir hi my name is grace Helbig
do not know now you know your life is
different now Coachella has ended I
think but no one knows because it
seemingly goes on forever but the second
week of Coachella has come to a close so
I thought like I do with a lot of
different event I would review some of
the more popular fashions that we saw at
Coachella 2017 I took some of your
suggestions from Twitter and then I
found some other photos online
let's review celebrity Coachella fashion
2017 we know Gomez and the weekend Wow
okay there are a couple now which is
cool they're cute they both look like
you know parents that are ready to take
their kids to a theme park and stand in
line for hours on end they packed the
appropriate Footwear other than that
Selena Gomez looks like a roll of fabric
from jo-ann fabric that is always on
sale because it's gorgeous
Selena looks very Celia circa 2010 girls
URL comm anyone out there fun place for
girls to connect and also an even more
fun place for like predators to never
mock and the weekend looks like how
quilt that a woman who frequents jo-ann
fabrics made for her emo nephew this one
looks a little bit like the weekend log
rolled down a hill or sh pants and then
log rolled down the hill and I'm okay
with that you got to do what you got to
do what music festivals bathrooms are at
a minimum you guys wait Lee Haeri Katy
Perry debuted a very short haircut at
Coachella and why not here's the caveat
to Coachella no one dresses in correctly
nor does anyone dress correctly
everyone's thrown like a thousand bouncy
balls in a very small queue all at the
same time that's like what I imagine
Coachella is side note I've never been
to Coachella so nothing that qualifies
me more for judging the fashion at
Coachella it's the fact that I've never
been to Coachella TV Paris giving me
sexy fred durst vibes and I don't
but Katy Perry also has a great sense of
humor about this because she posted on
4/20 a photo of her her new haircut I by
side with guys Yeti so I feel like she
makes fun of herself as much as everyone
else like Brianna this is why I could
show up and I also love Rihanna this is
exactly the more of this this is so
stupid
this is so stupid it's so smart and it's
so dumb and it's so I love every part of
this Rihanna
apparently walked around the festival
grounds wearing masks Da'Ville pulling
the bodysuit and no one knew that it was
Rihanna and I love that kind of SH and I
love that she also just put like a
normal festival outfit on top of it the
other thing I heard is that this suit
cost seventy five thousand dollars so
that's where this fun prank falls out of
my favor but other than that like yeah
this is kind of [ __ ] I want more of the
Coachella outfits to be and you're so
cool Rihanna but like I know you know
this is just stupid real hard
I love Lord I like her music I like her
energy her vibes might be a little
biased because she liked a tweet that I
tweeted about her and her song green
light she did not follow me but she
liked the tweet and that's the first
step to a real friendship this day job
it looks fun
feels like sexy Las Vegas showgirl on
top and like sexy insurance saleswoman
on the bottom tax season's over
fancy accountant get on that stage at
Coachella she always looks fun and
comfortable monsterbowl rolls off the
tongue like Orlando Bloom and Leonardo
DiCaprio I don't think you to anyone has
told them that by putting their hoods up
it doesn't make them invisible they were
still able to tell who they are maybe
their ears are just cold in the desert
maybe they both got carried away with
the music
oh and they got matching bro piercings
on their ears they're just a little
embarrassed by this position that they
made so they're just trying to keep them
under wraps I get a boy IRA piltan I
read somewhere that this is Paris
Hilton's 10th Coachella and you would
never be able to tell is Cheshire Cat is
in heat their body is glowing very
sweaty in a very glowy sexy way this is
like a really sexy boho party city
birthday banner that you turned into a
maxi dress and they think that's really
cute and the cat ears are without that
vibe but people should think cats are
sexy I don't get that so much but like
cool chests play and you're really doing
some fun heart eyes emoji cosplay here
yeah Kylie Jenner this doesn't look like
your typical Coachella and maybe that's
why I kind of like it the dress is very
like sexy South Jersey girl chainmail
the hair is very like I want to
Supercuts and got my hair bleached
blonde and then my friend that comes
from in my pool and her dad like over
chlorinated the pool and so it turned
kind of green and then I borrowed these
boots my brother who's in this Punjab
and and there we go I relate to this on
many many levels surprisingly when I
felt stevevls turn 15 sign be sexy meets
sweet we got some S&M Thai food wear
fishnets Bobby sue and then we got
shorts that look like mom let her
daughter get her first pair of like
short shorts but they're freely and cute
it looks like you shopped at the icing
and then also the serious girl section
the weekend before Easter you Rilke
Hudgens this is yeah you kept your
throne as the reigning queen of
Coachella Vanessa Hudgens if you don't
know is at this point just really known
for being a Coachella I feel like and
this year she wanted to make sure that
everyone knew their place
she got a Lisa Frank folder printed on
about 50 yards of fabric and she wrapped
around her body and she just flew off
real crappy and Scott Hoying
superfruit was that Coachella and day
look like superfruit look at these boys
you guys are so cute also I'm going to
use this as my Christmas card for 2017
is that okay I hope that's okay
subscribe ah look at this kid is this
not the cutest burglar you've ever seen
I'm sorry I am such an affinity for Troy
I just feel so proud of him so adult and
be so cool I like to get a lot of
unfinished ends on all of your clothing
so for anyone out there is OCD this is a
really complicated outfit to look at but
still very stylish I like it we can see
both of your knees so we understand that
you are with legs and not just standing
on wooden stilts that's cute and I just
like the whole like a horrible burglar
vibe the girls are ClevverTV oh my god I
don't know if you guys follow any other
girl from clever I love them so much
look at these girls they're having the
best time ever and if they're not
they're really really good at pretending
they're having the best time ever for a
great Instagram this looks like an ad
for a college that I would like to
attend may I enroll please thank you
okay that's it for my review of the
celebrity Coachella fashions from 2017
let me know who you guys loved and if I
miss anyone which happens constantly I'm
very sorry I cannot please all of you
but I hope Phillippe sees some love you
and you like nude fashion or new videos
give this video a thumbs up so I know
and subscribe to this YouTube channel I
make me do it Monday Wednesday and
Friday
sometimes other than that item this took
a lot of time for what is seemingly a
minor payoff ain't that just Coachella
though